[Music]
now what podcasts which bands this year
that matter this very corder there's
lord taco i'm brad hello again team
we are how many days away it's getting
close huh are you feeling it
yes
yeah definitely
good bad scared all of it
scared what are you scared about oh i
always get this way about this time
gets me up at night thinking
suddenly i can smell the porta-potties
all over again and yeah
yeah all that gary that's just your
basement i hate to tell you it's just
it's been a while
all right i buy that in the spray can
just to be familiar
taco you excited you feeling it i'm
excited i'm pumped are you
uh do you have the fever
no i tested negative okay
[Laughter]
he's always ready to get in that bus
always ready to get up in that butts
bust get all up
ready so it was a big week today we kind
of thought that the uh the schedule was
gonna come out uh today or at least this
week so um we'll go through the schedule
even though there's um
not much to go through uh and uh some
some news that we have and then some
personal news that we will share
on the uh the big show today uh i want
to start with um taco you know computers
much better than i do
is it me or is this schedule impossible
to read on this website it's impossible
to see it on the phone when i'm looking
on the website it's like i'm going to
send you a screenshot i'm going to print
my screen and then put it into like a an
email for you to see what i'm looking at
what am i doing wrong okay dad prince
i i can't even tell you how happy i am
with the line of this conversation
what do you want me to do okay wait a
second i was gonna say it but i refused
i refused to pick that in front of you
why don't you fax it to me
i'm sending it to you be a pigeon look
at the picture that i just sent you what
am i doing wrong i like i see one line
on a schedule and that's it what is
wrong with this this interface there's
something very wrong with this interface
nothing what i don't understand what do
you mean i sent you the picture you tell
me what i'm missing
what is that exactly
i don't know what you're missing i don't
know what i don't know
but like how am i supposed to want to
know
that's your only choice right there brad
that's it yeah what do you what are you
asking
like what is this suppose i don't know
how to look at this schedule
it's not easy to gather navigate i agree
i actually found somebody thankfully
posted it on reddit like okay like we're
used to seeing
yeah i need it i need it as a grid man i
need it as a grid i don't need you to do
all these funky little you know uh
bars that go left to right and then i
don't need any of that i just want the
damn grip well they they tweeted out
pictures that are in grid form i know
and thank god they did but i just went
to the website and it is so confusing i
i just don't know how to navigate this
thing it's not easy you do you do
agree with me that it's not easy
i agree and i think it's because there's
so many choices there's so many options
i don't know how else they
could have done it well i mean i liked i
like that grid form i like the pictures
i like the grids i mean i know i'm
sounding like get off my lawn here but i
uh it's pretty much
like but you're not wrong the other
thing too is like
i don't know i
having a harder and harder time every
year navigating their newfangled
technology they're trying to throw at me
i want the damn thing in a vcr and
that's it
put it in the vcr tell me where i'm
supposed to be and what time
[Laughter]
um i'm so glad you just said that
because today i've been trying to
navigate this thing and i'm like nope
i'm not sending it i just don't know why
they gotta make this so hard there's
like no need for this
this amount of of
of [ __ ]
just put it on a damn grid and make it
easier for me to to digest i cannot do
this any oh my god go look at what they
look go look at what they tweeted
because without pictures that's good
uh but a mat like have you tried to
watch this on your look at this on your
phone it's even worse yeah right i have
no idea how to navigate this thing on my
phone
your tip last week about you know put
the schedule as your home screen yeah
that ain't gonna work well no no that
you take the picture the picture that
they tweeted out you save that
and then use that as your home screen is
what i'm saying but even that what
doesn't have i mean this schedule that
they have has all the
the extra stuff they're there right now
y'all are yeah
oh thank god we know exactly how to
rectify your stress doctor okay what's
your question okay is that how i have to
get technical support around here
my id guy's gotta be drunk before he'll
answer a question about a website design
let's let's be honest for a festival
that does user experience so well this
is very very difficult to navigate okay
i'm not gonna be swayed on that it's
it's very difficult to navigate all
right uh before we get into anything
else and i'll stop complaining about it
what are your overall impressions around
the room of uh schedule 2022
well
that good huh all right good yeah uh
talk to you guys next week
45 days out
um had several days to think about it
thursday
i am gonna go with 2016. that's going to
be my whole theme my whole motif in all
of this
that that was if you remember
several reasons if you remember that was
the lowest uh turnout that they've ever
had but it was also one of our favorite
years i had a great time i thought it
was a great time yeah yeah it was great
it was uh
the the grounds were great the setup was
great we didn't know hardly anybody on
the lineup so we determined to have fun
and discover
and just let it you know whatever
happened happened and that's
after sort of you know struggling with
this saturday and yesterday and studying
a little more today that's kind of where
i've landed
don't know a lot of people on thursday
but that's typical
sunday did not look very good over the
weekend
uh still
not not a day that i would you know
choose to be my favorite
but there's some stuff on there that i
can work with uh friday and saturday are
okay
um
so there are not for me a lot of what
the typical you know when schedule comes
out you know you pull your hair out and
say oh my gosh my favorite band's
playing against my other favorite band
there's some conflicts but it's not
terrible
um i'll get to the biggest one i don't
quite understand later
if you want
uh or i can no i mean i i want to hear
what every whatever you think about the
schedule let me hear it i want to uh
good bad and different it doesn't matter
to me
uh i'm i don't quite understand the uh
super jam
being a six o'clock
in the evening
okay you're you're hitting something
that i hadn't even noticed yet but you
are exactly right what is with that man
i mean that's late night after eight
yeah super jam
i don't man i don't know that's just
it's supposed to be a late night thing
not an early afternoon i mean that's a
that's a walk by at this point
yeah
and that's one of the better that's one
of the better things on saturday
absolutely
and it probably it's up against mount
joy
uh you know who i'd like to see it's not
necessarily against a lot of things but
it kind of
i don't know i mean to to build jude and
the lion over jack antonoff super jam is
um quite bold
yeah
it's
i don't i don't understand it
um
yeah it would go right into super jam
and then judah although if you were to
if you were to look at saturday the
saturday late night is probably the
better of the two late nights um
correct me if i'm wrong what do you
think because i i'm i'm going through
the friday late night now yeah i'm all
in on the the saturday late night
weirdly enough it does feel as though
the friday schedule is better than
saturday the saturday late night seems
to be a little stronger but overall boy
the bookends are
maybe the two weakest thursday and
saturday sundays we i've ever seen of
this festival yeah i agree i agree
i agree in that middle what are we
talking six o'clock five o'clock until
whatever on
friday probably is the only the real
conflicts for me interesting what
because mainly that's barry's nap time
[Laughter]
um
well yeah i gotta recover from
wednesday and third wednesday and
thursday
uh but no you've got uh robert plant
isaiah rashad who we've mentioned many
times the chattanooga guy the regrets
i'm just going across japanese breakfast
uh war on drugs
you know leading into the chicks who
like i said i i want to see
um
so that that's
those that couple of hours is probably
the biggest conflict time yeah i mean
it's for yeah i would actually agree i
think your friday
um block there of war on drugs arlo
parks bleachers are probably the only
spot where i feel like oh man that's you
just knocked out three of the very few
acts i wanted to see to begin with
um and i would i'd really have to make a
choice uh because man i love arlo parks
she's incredible
and i've seen war on drugs a whole bunch
of times so
um
bleachers are touring everywhere so
there's a very good chance they've
already come through your city and if
you really wanted to see them you
already would have so maybe the answer
becomes pretty easy after that and it's
harlow parks but um but yeah it does
feel like that's the only place where
maybe the overnight the late night stuff
where you know you're probably at least
i am bouncing from one show to the next
uh late night i i i feel like you're
probably right that's the only spot
where i feel a little bit of
um difficulty now
uh rubber plant's great but you know
japanese breakfast i've got to give
another shot
you know i can't let that last show
bonnaroo
right
be the taste in my mouth because i just
i like her way too much to to give up on
that band
yeah and i didn't see it yet it's uh on
earth to watch but uh the saturday night
live
show went well from everything i read
right i watched it
i oh
i think that she's just an artist that
you're either going to really love or
just not
connect with and
i love her i really do i didn't really
understand that saturday live
performance i really like i said i
haven't seen it yet uh
king gizzard only for an hour a little
little strange but as as we've been told
many times by uh
the guys who booked this thing and and
the promoters uh you know who we had on
it's at the request of the bands right
it's not that the uh it's not that
bonnaroo has said hey you got an hour
they they pretty much book them for what
they asked for right
well they only played an hour at
shakinese and that felt criminally too
short
that seems to me like about two songs
from what i've you know yeah they're
just getting warmed up right just
getting sweaty
yeah um
do you have goose on there for two so so
your overall impression is that you
you tended to think that friday or
thursday and sunday was light there
weren't a lot of uh conflicts because
there frankly weren't a lot of things
that you wanted to see
um is that pretty much the the
gist of it i think you hit the word um
and it's a word i was thinking about
this you know for first three or four
years i went by myself
covering it for the paper and it's
pretty much
i don't know that i coined the word but
i sure used it a lot which was walk by
uh taco this if i would have said if i
would walk by if i would have ever said
the words
i coined a phrase you guys would
never ever you'd put it on a goddamn
t-shirt you would never let me live it
down if i said well i coined the phrase
dispute me
it's true i have to pay barry every time
i use the word
how in the world would i get away with
that
how in the world would i get away with
saying guys
i created a phrase that you guys use all
the time and that's how cool i am yeah i
mean you know you're the one who told us
you invented netflix
that's right that's right
and the bubbles
and satellite television too by the way
[Laughter]
yeah i had to give you something to pick
on
no but honestly it just feels this feels
like a walk by
there's more walk by days and more barry
this thing feels like a walk-by festival
yeah
all right taco your initial impressions
what do you think
pretty much the same i mean it's very
light and i'm happy about it yeah i mean
uh this is where yeah
this feels like just a regular camping
trip for you
pretty much i mean
two years of not having it i mean
we're gonna need time to just get
reacquainted and get settled back in
there's so many people that i want to
meet up with and see and talk to that i
haven't been able to for the past couple
years
so the fact that i'm not like on a very
stringent
band schedule means i've just got more
you've got to float around and you've
got more time for moms
yeah got more time yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
taco and i are going to be walking
around asking if the bands can turn it
down a little because we're trying to
talk
i i had plans in this tent um can you
guys just move along
can you see we're talking here
we're trying to have dinner here please
hey black tiger sex machine can we move
it along
man that band is loud
we we have historically on this on this
podcast try to be very positive and try
to be optimistic the whole reason why we
started it's also you know part of the
the bonnaroo
ethos but man
this is really a struggle
this is
i feel as as bad of a bond or lineup as
we've ever had and i and i just feel
like this might be one of the worst
festival lineups of the entire season
now with all that being said
next year will be great you know last
year would have been great
um it's not like
this is a problem it's just one of those
years where
it's a struggle every festival is having
a struggle as they you know stumble and
get you know pretty lucky but man this
is just
this is rough and i know that we've said
this before that whenever we get really
excited about a lineup we wait until we
see it on a schedule because then it
starts to change our thought about it
all i mean i'm never gonna live down the
fact that i was over the moon about aco
fest two years ago and then when i see
the schedule actually laid out i'm like
this kind of sucks
i get that there's like um
i don't know
nothing about this seems very exciting
to me which brings me to a little bit of
personal news it's not something that
you guys would probably care about but
someone alerts cnn they'll be on the
ticker for the rest of the night
this is the first time in 16 years i'm
not going to be at bonnaroo um and i and
i can't tell you
with 100 certainty that it's because of
my current life situation
um
i think that if without if for those who
haven't caught up i
took a job with a rock station in new
york city and i'm up here not only doing
that um programming that and then a
station detroit and the station in
miami but i'm also on the air
at this alternative station in new york
which was howard stern's
station which is kind of badass but um
at least personally
so even if that stuff wasn't happening
if the lineup was better i
might have found a way to get there for
a day or two in fact barry uh when i was
talking about this job with you months
and months and months before
i even said well maybe i come down for a
day or two maybe the flights are cheap
to nashville maybe i'll just come in
stay in nashville and then and drive in
for a couple of days
i don't even have the i don't even have
the bandwidth or the interest to do that
and okay i hate saying it i really do
because you know how much i love this i
i there's nothing on here that i i'm
absolutely
killing myself to go to so it would have
to be well bonner is never not great
all right let me figure out a way to get
there because i know it's going to be
great well
the only difference with that and i do
agree with it
boy the whole
not in in just totally investing every
bit of energy into camp nut butter
is hard for me to wrap my head around
um not being able to just get completely
immersed in
the giant cartoon heads and
the lit marquee and all of the carpet
and all the goofiness that we bring to
camp not being able to do that just
getting on a plane and coming in for a
day just feels so sterile
um and i don't necessarily want to
experience bonnaroo that way so
um
it's a combination of a lot of things
and
i i just
maybe if there was something on here
that was
was needle moving i would
i would change my mind but the boy it's
it's this is this is rough going
like i said it it started on saturday
for me really uh
well let me go back we've had two and a
half years to think about it and it
when we didn't go it's sort of as you i
think you mentioned it several weeks ago
it it altered the rhythm of things and
it gave us all a chance to
take stock of
everything
uh you know so it it
i know what you're saying
uh if this if the lineup from 2020 was
this year's lineup
i have a feeling you'd be feeling you're
probably gonna have to have yeah you're
probably right um even if i if i and i
know i'm talking on both sides of my
mouth but yeah you're probably right um
i look at sunday
and i just i wonder if there will be
anybody there by
eight nine o'clock um well here let me
go back
so we should probably you know that is
news and you know
we're we're both gonna miss you i mean
it's going to be a very small camp nut
butter
for sure
but from what we're hearing it's going
to be a very small bonnaroo
and i was thinking about that as well i
go back to 2016. and part of the reason
you know ken weinstein who is the media
person and and has become a friend of
the show and
and was on our show by the way who
actually coined who coined the phrase
never not great basic
i see what you did there
it kind of kind of hurt a little bit
i'm gonna have to prove it arnold i'm
gonna have to go back and document show
receipts um but who did coin the phrase
never not great from 2016 which was the
smallest crowd ever
in uh you know what were going on 20
years it was great and it's partly
because everybody that is there wants to
be there and that makes a huge
difference about this festival yes true
you know we've all been to we've all
been to events where you know the
numbers could be good but it was still
there
i mean i i had an absolute
blast in 2016. it was one of it was the
of all the the boundaries i it's got to
be in my top three i mean if not
if not
my favorite year that we've had so the
crowd size is not going to be a problem
um but yeah to your point i know i know
this information is out there because
sponsors are starting to to
share it but
i mean i didn't hear 35k
i heard 25k
and when sponsors hear 35k
the reason why they're hearing that
number is because they're being told a
number so it'll justify the paycheck or
the justify the check that they're about
to write so
whatever you hear a sponsor say uh
subtract a little bit of a fraction out
of that because they're overestimating
for sponsors to make them feel as though
their money is worthwhile to be spent
with bonnaroo i was told 25k
and the next day i heard less than 30.
so whatever that means to you
um
it to me it means
the things that we saw in 2016 are back
there the fences moved in
the the spaces got smaller so it didn't
feel so vast and empty but more
importantly for those who have been to
exit 111 taco berry it's going to feel a
lot like that yes
i was about to ask what was the numbers
for exit 111 because this feels like
this is about the attendance for exit
111.
and it they did shrink it a bit they
brought cenaru in tighter uh they had
some of the campgrounds closed so it
didn't feel as empty right but it was
definitely smaller
i mean that's but most of those people
never went to bottom they didn't know
exactly that and that's the thing that
uh brad and i reminded ourselves
you know after 2016. i mean when we got
there for media day and noticed that how
how closed in the fence was on the the
what stage area
it was like you know mind blowing and
then
the people who've never been would have
no idea so what's the big deal you know
it still felt like a very good large
festival
bands were great yep everything by the
time you're there you're not gonna give
a damn that's only twenty five thousand
people right now you're not gonna in
fact you're gonna love it you're gonna
love the fact that there's no lines for
bathrooms and no lines for showers and
you know you're gonna be able to get
right up front you're gonna get but i
will but i will say
i mean just just
with all the experience that you have on
this farm i really weren't worried that
there's gonna be
seven thousand people for the stevie
nicks show come sunday
i mean it does that's really sad that
question
you know what and there's
as we've said many many times there's
nothing worse than an empty room i mean
even if it's a you know
if if it's a room that holds 10 and only
two show up two is still a good number
for some events but it feels yeah i mean
taco you're there is your question was
how many people were at exit 111 by
their accounts it was 25k
and that was with
that's about that sounds about half of
the
um square footage
so you know they're they're
now is that is that
i got a follow-up question is that
tickets sold or is that attendance
because when you roll in yeah vendors uh
oh attendance so vendors volunteers
uh workers yeah closer to that yeah you
could get to 35k
um yeah but
and the other thing too is is roundabout
now it's not like you're going to be
getting um an extra i don't know 20 000
tickets being sold you know no you're
not gonna get a lot of walk up at an
event like this
um i do wonder
um
you know they're still doing the load in
on tuesday and wednesday
which was a good idea
on paper and i don't know no way that
they can change that now there's no way
no i can't change it but the reason was
they were going to be you know trying to
figure out how to get 90 000 people into
a 700 acre farm
uh you know without long lines and all
that long delays and all that so
i have no idea how many people signed up
for tuesday load in or wednesday load in
uh as we look at the schedule thursday
music starts around four
so you know if you come in on tuesday at
what time you've got a good
two and a half full days of
now you know play
play bonnaroo pr for a second um what do
you think the reason is for the light
attendance this year
i mean oh my god number one play play pr
member of
bonnaroo
um
if i'm them
i'm going to say pretty much what we've
said there are a lot of choices
um
people have made their choices maybe
adding that extra day
is not what people wanted maybe it's the
economy maybe we're coming out of
the uh
pandemic
now i mean i would spend more time in
and color it better than i'm coloring it
right now
but i i think those are all legit and i
think those are what they're going to
say they're they're not going to say
it's a lineup
you know because
they're going to say it's always it's
never not great it's still going to be
great it's always a fun time it's a time
for community
well to be fair a lot of things that you
said are actually true
you know not only is the the economy
really tough we're coming out of a
we're coming out of a a
pandemic where people are making
different choices about where they're
spending their money and they're being
they're having to be very very uh
specific with the things that they
choose to do not just with their dollars
but with their time
and you know
it's not like all the other festivals
are blowing up and
blowing the doors off the place there
are a few spaces where they're doing
really well um i i'd like to know what
the hangout number ended up being over
the over the past weekend but you know
lollapalooza hasn't sold out yet they
anticipate they're going to sell it acl
sold out in a day when we were young
sold out multiple times but other than
that are you really seeing
a lot of a lot of movement on the big
scale i don't know what coachella ended
up um doing but did i hear that they
sold out i don't i don't think i did
maybe
russ you said shaky knees was great
right big crowds
shaking these felt like you had a big
crowd it didn't feel any smaller than
last year yeah but yeah that's the only
two years i've been but because it's a
city festival and it's so much easier to
access and so much easier for locals to
to be a part of um you know bonuro
becomes a yes honorable becomes
difficult and it becomes hard to
yeah it becomes a hard yeah
shakiness
had a great lineup yeah
yeah i i mean what
going back to the earlier question what
does happen if the 2020 lineup is this
year's lineup i i don't i mean that was
a heck of a lineup it's hard to imagine
that we at least don't double whatever
the bonnaroo number is i do think that
it's a very good point
barry is that they uh
it never ends up being about the lineup
and
there are i i understand i'm telling you
until it does i would argue i think that
bonnaroo has done such a great job of
being post lineup right they've figured
out a way to create an incredible
um atmosphere that is not line up
dependent well
you know
maybe we're entering into a world
maybe we have we've entered to a world
where things are different and the
lineup is going to be very lineup
dependent now what you're asking
somebody to do is a big
it's a load of effort to do
this over a course of a few days
and
you know people's options are wider and
faster and closer
but you you said earlier yourself next
year they come back you know the the
ones that are going want to go
right i mean let's we all agree on that
right i think that what we said this
isn't a this it's never uh it's never a
halfway right there's there is i feel
like there was a comment i feel like
there was a comment uh a few years ago
when we said
when it was 60 000 people for lcd sound
system and pearl jam in den company i
think
we had i i i feel like i'm remembering
this correctly
well
30 000 is the base
you're never going to get less than 30
000 because
um if half of the crowd or new
bonnaroovians and new people to the
festival uh 30
30 000 half of 60 was i really do think
like 30 is their
drop dead base number
and so long as they get there they're
gonna be okay
okay and so that was i guess kind of
where i was going so that those 30 show
up and have you know another good time
and they're gonna tell a friend and
bring a friend and
you know maybe next year's lineup comes
out early and it's it's amazing and some
of these other ones as we've said you
know how many of them survive
i
i really do feel like this is a
transition year where we're going to see
some go away and some survive well i
don't don't get too crazy with that
barry because you got you'll get uh you
know conspiracy theorists who see
uh the state of tennessee i'm sorry not
the state of tennessee it was the state
of tennessee in the city of manchester
uh putting the screws to bonnaroo and
bonnaroo fighting back and saying well
we don't need to do this here
um so
you start you start saying stuff like
that it's gonna get people
you know a little rocky it's gonna make
them feel a little
itchy could be could very well be there
could be a lot of things going on behind
doors we don't know about but what we do
know is it's
live nation right which
c3 has
plenty of money and
they do own the farm so they're you know
we would like to think committed
it's not you know it's not a a small
thing
but you're right
they're big enough too they could walk
away and yeah i mean it's i
could it's not
the way that it was told to me i think
we've said this before it's not like
bonnaroo makes them
a lot of money
i mean it makes them enough to keep
going and it is a valuable part of the
whole asset
and and part of the whole you know
structure and
you know but it's not like they're
blowing the doors off making a ton of
money here they have a just a shitload
of overhead uh that a city festival just
doesn't have to
have to engage in um
so
i guess the next couple of weeks as we
lead up to this and by the way if you
haven't listened to
the episode from last week where it's
basically bonnaroo do's and don'ts it's
a good precursor on how to get ready for
any sort of festival that you might uh
find yourself in the summer but
if you get time go back and listen to
that but barry uh next week your picks
taco picks what do we got
will these be the shortest episodes in
what podcast history
[Laughter]
we might be able to just call it yeah
maybe we ought to record them both at
the same time
you know just fix yeah we probably
probably should just walk by wb i think
that's right
one episode of this
uh
yeah let's both be ready taco we'll see
where it goes okay um i'll be right back
yeah no i there are pics um you know
back to this lineup i there aren't a lot
of those uh conflicts are the ones and
that's usually what we talk about it all
the other thing i will say
and i don't think we've said today we
have said in the past
not every lineup is for everybody i do
know some people who are excited about
that and they should be for people who
like this are going to have a blast
um
and i really honestly and i i know
you're going to laugh but
i i plan to spend some time over at the
other uh there i want to find out some
of those uh the edm and the
trap bands and the house bands and all
that so
now's this is as good a year if i'm ever
gonna do it
um
you know
especially some of you later you won't
be missing much else some of the late
nights i mean so and i and and we didn't
really talk about with this schedule
though we have mentioned it many many
times we might end up i'd like to say
taco taco you didn't hear what barry
said to me i might have to be looking
for him say this to you but on the phone
the other day he goes
i'm thinking about camping out in ga
if i yeah maybe really he did mention
that to me the other day and and
i mean it's going to be a very
different camp nut butter and i kind of
felt bad kyle the the bonoruvian wrote
me on snapchat the other day he's like
hey i got a media pass i'm finally
coming back to see camp nut butter i
said uh
oh okay tell me bring a chair
oh yeah yeah
yeah can you bring a full-length mirror
because we're not gonna have one you got
any fencing and some carpet
there you want to do a chicken pen when
you're uh
yeah
i'm glad i didn't get that chicken last
year oh my god if you had a pet chicken
right now that you're hanging on for
bonnaroo
you would have eaten it
a live chicken to bonner sneak a chicken
in and have a chicken pin so that you
was it gonna be a rooster that's gonna
wake everybody up or was it just gonna
be
that was gonna be i i it's funny we we
went back to the paper into the building
for the first time a couple of weeks ago
and i still have the post-it note on my
computer screen
chickens
it's been there for two years
it made me laugh we'd have you would
we'd have fresh eggs everything probably
just other chicks right about now i feel
like that chicken have a few extra
members of the family
i just picture you know that scene in
the hangover when they wake up you know
people waking up with
camp nut butter and there's chickens
hey maybe it's a little foreshadowing
because barry writes down on a post at
chickens and this year we have the
chicks wow
wow i don't think that's a coincidence
jerry
it's mary would scribble down your table
right now
give me the first note that you see
oh my god i want to know you too
i knew it no it's even worse
it's a work it's a reminder
i called myself a [ __ ]
in the on the note is there a band
called the morons
is there a that'd be a good the morons
maury povich is coming
more povich
call it it now
i
i just i don't know i um
i lo
it feels bad to say because i love this
festival so much um but
do you feel like and separate yourself
for a second
is there anybody around you and this
might be circumstantial but is there
anyone around you excited about it
is there anybody that you
know that's going that's really excited
about it um you guys are you know an
hour away from bonnaroo do you see local
people talking about it
that's a fair question and and it hurts
me to say but no other than taco and
brian stone you know our typical camp
nut butter bunch
no
yeah i mean i i don't really haven't
really talked to anyone outside of our
little bubble of people that are already
going so i haven't heard any you know
word on the street about it take that
back daniel of course daniel and uh
is
the rubus those guys are over the moon
they have a huge event uh planned for
tuesday and and uh
and they should be excited and it it's
gonna be a fun so but they're they
honestly uh they and the red roo guys
and and a lot of the regulars
uh are every bit as excited like like we
are
uh but to your question am i hearing
you know and like you said we're an hour
away and usually my kids and their
friends you know would be all excited
about it and quite honestly they're more
excited about river bend than they are
bonnaroo
but
you know i've listened and i've seen
some of the online stuff
there are a lot of people excited and
they're not just regulars there are
people for whom like a lot of these edm
bands are
are it's a great lineup
to a lot of them so
i and i'm
the more i studied this schedule today
and the more i thought about 2016
and and part of that is just pumping
myself up and getting ready um
it'll be fun that now what it looks like
i still
i know that this is so subjective and it
always comes back to you know who you
like versus who you don't like so
somebody who's spending a lot of time
with the other i'm sure
really really likes this line if that's
fine uh but i keep coming back to 2016
and i don't think it's bad i don't think
there's a you know it may not be stacked
it may not be thick around the middle
but boy there's still so much on there
that is
um
that was incredible lcd m83 tame impala
saint lucia grizz allen stone all in one
day tyler the creator on one day the
chain smokers on one day vince staple on
the same day that was just one day
um
did we ever decide why that line that
year was so low
did we ever determine a reason was it
just because there were so many other
festivals all of a sudden that's my
memory you know i don't i do not
remember um
i don't remember an explanation as to
why exactly that year and and why would
i have a terrible memory um but still
i'm keep i keep coming back to this line
i think that friday alone was was better
than the the whole festival combined um
and i know somebody's gonna rip me apart
for saying that but you know bob moses
was the friday opener so was blood
orange you know i know i'm sorry they
were the last one but like i there were
some really really solid uh bands on
that lineup and then you go to saturday
the the opener for the what stage was
grace potter
um
i don't know man there's a there's a lot
there from 2016 that i think is still
pretty good post malone was on the other
tent in 2016. he was the sec third
person to play in 2016. post malone
yeah there will be there will be those
that come out of this year you know
those names that
we look back
hard to say going in but uh no i i get
what you're saying and i i really wish
we could go back and try to remember
what it was about 16
or the theory i i think it was
kind of like this year where it was just
a you know a confluence of a lot of
different factors including there were a
whole lot of i really don't remember i i
just don't remember
i'm certain of it i think we went from
you know several dozen to several
hundred
within that time and there's
you know no i mean look i think i think
that if you're around as long as
bonnaroo and coachella i mean coachella
has got just just an
outrageous amount of money but um
when you're this big you're going to
have bad years i can't express to you
how many bad years lollapalooza's had i
mean
every year that my lollapalooza group
just looks at each other like why are we
going to this you know like
but
but i always end up going i always end
up having a great time and guess what
it's always sold out
so something is something still connects
with that brand something still connects
but it will be back and it'll be fine
also the other thing too that i equate
it to people like us talking about stuff
like this is a lot of times like when
sports or football dudes talk about the
nfl salary cap you know and they've got
an opinion on what team well well
they're just spending way too much money
on these players they're going to be
over the salary cap how are they going
to be under the salary
who gives a [ __ ] it's not your money
well it's also like arguing over this
year's championship team could never
play with you know the championship team
from 20 years if you are if you are a
fan of the festival and if you go to one
of these things what do you care if the
lineup is good or not you're going just
to have fun because it's what you did
you're part of your you know
it's part of your dna at this point
that's the point
we are it's a point i've been trying to
make today
that's exactly the point i've been
trying to make today yeah yeah i don't
care what the number is that we're an
hour away i mean i've driven further for
worse things than a bad boner i know i
know i met her um
but barry i will say that if i still
lived there i probably would be spending
all of this time just making camp right
you know this would be the year that we
would be going crazy making camp nuts um
yeah another thing about it yeah because
there's not much else to do you know
so we can't better be balling yeah we
would
we would be chicken yes would have been
the chicken this would have been the
dixie chicken here this would be the
chicken
so yeah i i get it it's um
it didn't help
i mean it lost some of its mojo i don't
know how else to put it and having to
cancel for two years
uh and then you know the way they sort
of handled it not being able to make
refunds it sort of lost
some mojo and and i think that and these
other ones
have you know come online and they're
probably closer and they maybe you know
fit the line whatever the reasons that's
why i keep saying this feels like a
reset year
in a lot of ways but when
these people who show up like us we're
going to have a great time and we're
going to talk it up again and we're
going to want you to come back and
everybody else and i'll be back i'll be
back i mean it's very sad and i and i i
had to come to grips with it a couple
weeks ago i really really didn't want to
um
to miss it because you know it means so
much to me but it's just there's just no
possible way there's no possible way
oh it would
i i mean when you said that i
it would be a really tough struggle
for you i don't know how you would do it
i mean before you lived here and you you
know had all your camping stuff
downstairs like
the rest of us and you throw it in the
car we get in there and we're there 55
minutes later
uh it wouldn't be that easy for you this
year yeah well uh before we get to the
final topic of the day anything else on
the schedule before we get to uh the
picks next week anything else you wanna
you wanna get to
i i don't remember was there anything
else i'll just throw in beer exchanges
friday eleven to one i mean well i you
don't don't give away all the picks russ
don't
all right now take next week off spoiler
alert
um i wanted to to give a uh i just want
to pay a little bit of attention i don't
know how much attention you paid to it
what hangout did over the weekend so not
only did hangout have to navigate
a just a tour
terrible storm
tremendous storm that ripped through
hangout festival uh but they did it
while losing a headliner and replacing
it in 24 hours um
so
russ do you remember do you know the
story about how hangout lost a a
headliner and then had to replace with
grizz
no
oh wow you guys were following this over
the weekend oh was it this year
yeah it was two days ago oh oh two days
ago no i i didn't pay attention
i did see all the tweets yeah i saw this
thing right now
everybody clear out yeah
so
uh on saturday one of the headliners for
hangout festival was supposed to be
dojicat
and she had
she had a surgery or something yeah she
had like tonsil surgery throat surgery
or something like that
and she was immediately replaced out of
nowhere by grizz and by all accounts had
an absolutely incredible
show
yeah which you know it just proves your
point about bonnaroo you know maybe
you're in a different area this year
barry and spending some time with some
spaces that you never would have
seen before but the fact that
they
were able to swing that so quickly and
dealt with the weather they've had to
deal with there is not a year that i can
remember where hangout has not lost a
headliner i don't know how this keeps
happening but you know they lose frank
ocean one year one year they lose like
the weekend i don't know they lost
somebody and then the last second
they're replacing with mumford and sons
like every year feels like they're
losing somebody up at the top and it's
almost built baked into the cake of
hangouts like well
30 of this is not going to exist here
when we get there and then you have to
you have to deal with the weather um and
the fact that like that looked like on
on saturday and friday like the thing
was going to be shut down and completely
collapsed
they have a new director
for hangout and i don't remember quite
remember when he got here there but his
name is reeves and i'm dying to meet him
and i'm dying to talk to him because um
from all accounts he's a really really
really smart smart dude and you know we
know the guy that ran
hang out before
and you know a lot of this was set up
for them to succeed but i'm really
interested to see if we could ever find
reeves to talk to to talk exactly about
how
they were able to swing something in
through all of the
with all the stuff that they had to deal
with in one weekend i i'd love to get
some perspective on that
yeah they i mean as we've learned from
again talking to jeff quayle who you
know basically was always in the room at
bon rou they know what they're doing
they plan for these
uh he's he's told us before at bonnaroo
and i know hangout has the same they all
do i mean they have entire
you know control centers that are just
monitoring the weather
uh they're monitoring traffic they're
doing all this kind of stuff they they
have a plan and uh
like like i said earlier when you were
looking it up we saw it at four castle
and even that looked like a disaster but
they got that place cleared out pretty
quickly
you know um
it's amazing it
as as you've said a couple of times here
in the last several shows i think the
logistics of it is part of what we love
about these things
you know it's not just the
music and the bands and the fun it's all
of that but it's
it's watching professionals who know
what they're doing run a major
event like this
so
and i mean that's part of what i'm
looking forward to in a couple of three
weeks is to see how they adjust so with
all that being said reeves we'd like to
have you on the show give me a call
please please
please come on man um yeah because we
may not have much to talk about here in
the next uh couple of days
speaking of one with
going back to the lineup uh because it
came up on on some of the discussions
all them which is
we thought canceled their summer but
they're still on the lineup uh it looks
like and i looked on their website
they're it looks like they're doing
bonnaroo and then taking the right yeah
i was uh i wasn't sure if we were going
to get all them witches or just some of
them witches or none of them witches but
we got all their witches
barry did you write that down at your
desk too i want to make sure to mention
it
it was on my it was on my chicks and
witches
chicks and witches
chicks and witches chicks and mentions
all right anything else before we go
i feel like this is sort of a downer
night and i don't want it to be i feel
like a debbie downer and i feel bad now
for me
that's it's a downer you're not coming
but no yeah
we'll miss you i mean you'll be all
right you'll survive yeah but i mean
i think out of all the years to miss
you probably picked the ogre i picked
the right one huh i picked the right
yeah yeah um it's it's
it's definitely not uh ideal but um you
know
there's something like this i just i
can't there's there's no possible way i
can get out of the city
all right um well next week
next week picks yeah barry since it's
just us you you want to cuddle in the
bus
bus
i think we might have to from
things get up in them guts
[Music]
did you write that down yeah put it down
barry write it down put it down bus
cuddles all right
all right the what podcast we'll talk to
you again next week
[Music]
consequence podcast network